yo estoy muy emocionada por el tablero y
la información instantánea que recibo y
que ellos reciben nos enseña donde no
están entendiendo algo tanto para ellos
como para mí para que pueda ayudarlos y
que ellos reconozcan las áreas que
necesitan mejorar y creo que can ha
hecho un gran trabajo en hacerlo
sencillo para el usuario
puedo usar la información para dividir a
los alumnos en grupos puedo concentrarme
en los que están batallando mucho en
ciertas áreas también puedo ver al grupo
como un todo por ejemplo si el grupo
termina un módulo como este de múltiplos
comunes y si ya lo dominan antes de que
yo lo enseñe en clase
entonces ya sé que no tengo que
dedicarle tanto tiempo a esto así que
como maestro me ha liberado mucho tiempo
que puedo usar de manera más eficiente
está ahí disponible inmediatamente te da
una idea rápida dónde están los alumnos
dónde están teniendo problemas dónde
están batallando yo sé con quién tengo
que trabajar y en que los puedo ayudar
donde puedo apoyarlos y proponer
soluciones
he recibido correos de padres que dicen
tenemos problemas con la tarea y yo
puedo revisar y encontrar el ejercicio
específico que le está causando
problemas y así planear mi clase para el
día siguiente con este alumno me enseñan
za es más informada más focalizada fija
más alto tu objetivo de lo que debieras
planificar para tus alumnos una vez que
obtienes toda esa información a la que
es muy fácil acceder dice tal vez la
lección que pensaba que estaba bien para
toda la clase esté bien solo para el 20%
de ella debería replantearme en lo que
les estoy pidiendo a mis alumnos durante
los últimos tres años al promediar la
calificación de los alumnos de nuevo
ingreso la evaluación en álgebra dio 17%
exactamente la misma cifra la última
generación no utilizaba can está bien
utiliza con la misma enseñanza y el
mismo profesor tal como somos realmente
no hemos cambiado kahn está cambiando y
nuestras calificaciones son mucho más
altas el promedio del año pasado fue de
37%
años 72% estaba entusiasmado por mis
alumnos porque vi que es una herramienta
para ellos y que al final de cuentas los
va a ayudar a hacerse responsables de su
propio aprendizaje
no